petr où on est à ce jour son histoire
d'amour avec paula leclair alias julien
clerc parolier romancier les succès
jamais assis les compils rené gilles
etienne etienne mauricienne hors d'âge
ils saluent alors tu es né à montauban
oui d'un père anarchiste catalan va
exiger un syndicaliste
anarcho-syndicaliste réfugié en france
pour fuir le régime franquiste et tu dis
je suis né au milieu des fusils
contrat compte voilà oui et on sera
content après en fait pendant ce n'est
pas de dire que c'est un modifier quoi
que ce soit juste un petit enfant du
tarn et garonne compte tenu qu'ils en
font un quart des garonne et pas mal de
petits enfants du tarn et garonne avait
diffusé sur des livres ouais c'est
peut-être le mur de jeux pas seulement
de tarn et garonne et de l'ariège le
gers la saisir oui voilà
et donc non sera rien changé mais après
tout raconte que tu sais bien que tu me
racontes des histoires et que ouais bon
ça ça crée un caractère quoi tu penses
quoi de l'évolution de l'espagne
actuelle bah écoute ou nawa républicain
ouais un social-démocrate au pouvoir en
boissons nous mêmes à quoi et comme
arroyo tes camarades alors moi je dis
que ça va pas assez vite ça je sais bien
que je lui connais bien c'est ce que je
veux que tu me dises vais pas te le dire
je veux pas te dire quant aux moyens
courriers pas trop dire la nasa va pas
parce que on a perdu la guerre quoi
fouet ce jour après celle ci fait pas
comme santiago carillo qu'à passer
l'épongé
non non je n'y a aucune éponge il ya le
drapeau le long pont d'espagne idées ou
journaux les points et entre 18 et 22
ans tu t'es tu t'es balader ou et voir
avec des malus qui s'ouvre à laon les
maisons d'édition comme ça mais tiennent
et toi bien ouais bah je me suis fait
acheter notre dignité entre 18 et bones
dont je me suis fait jeter par tous les
éditeurs marines vraiment cruellement
tafer licence de lettres et tous les
sens des mots tels dérapages aubigny
c'était deux espagnols peinent à rester
peinard genre les soutenir j'ai été
assistant propre vitry par un jour et tu
voyais comment ton avenir
un jour dans un bistrot à anthony n'en
portent déjà des noms mais déjà place
déjà place à l'écritoire place en bonne
voie dans les deux sens ouais la
rencontre avec le leader idole bouclé de
quoi tu veux qu'on parlait pas parler de
ça ou alors c'était pas aussi bonnes
design moi je finissais donc d'espérer y
avait un petit groupe il c'est vrai que
jouer les animals web on l'arrête vous
avec des membres et des bombes bien
ouais ouais tu as rencontré julien clerc
s'était angoissante maintenant 67
comment il s'appelait voilà le plein à
sa durée de 10 ans alors je vais bon on
a brûlé le rayon ouais ouais t'as vu
barbelivien dans l'émission qui disait
que j'irais là il y aurait eu des gens
comme roda gil et maurice valises le
même est parti ouais on le comprend où
il a raison de dire ça
bon un moment je crois que il faut vous
faire des paris la fin paris
moi je vais moins il a bien fait ou voit
sa carrière depuis tulle analyse comment
match de l'iscom l'intérieur de
quelqu'un qui a essayé de de ne pas
vivre l'âge qu'il avait au parler très
bêtement alors que moi je l'entends la
fille aux bannis vend par exemple ça
fait quoi
bah ça fait que je pense que la fille de
la viande est je suis déçu poèmes qu'il
ya des belles le divorce s'est passé
comment plus ou moins bon on peut le
dire maintenant il ya presque la même
la prescription doit en plus le jour où
la gestion que plus chef de la création
ouais encore sa tombe avec ses dents et
comme quand on chante au nom de la
bouche
quel sens et formule qui doivent écrire
des chansons est ce que tu penses que
vous allez travailler ensemble à nouveau
et quoi quoi pourquoi tu crois pas
d'affaires est consommé là j'aimerais
bien j'avais pas dire mieux parce que le
propos de l'amour s'est jamais un propos
de gucci à mon avis un civet si c'est
vraiment un propos d'amour c'est pas de
la revanche
mais disons que je pense tu vas sourire
finement parce qu'on est très tard le
soir
mais disons que je ne pense pas avoir
menti pendant cette période là donc il
est possible que si je le faisais
maintenant il est possible que j'irai à
la pause
ouais au moins je te le dis comme ça tu
as raison alors à ce moment là tu fais
les magnolias pour klauk la non mais
c'est important qu'ils aient fait ça
parce qu'il est vieux mais je les trahir
chanson de claude françois est très fier
parce que c'est les magnolias alexandrie
mais je suis fier de ça je le fais je le
fais je le fais traumatique membres un
bon je vois notre tour dans ma tante
répondu hardy et j'ai surtout fait le
bond soudain de le fermer le lac majeur
du cygne un abri et alors ce lac majeur
ont fait très bien cet ami à l'abri il
faut pas une maison au bord du lac
majeur
mais non il faut parler des choses comme
elles sont c'est à dire que je sais de
la monoculture on peut on peut on peut
dire ça à sortir comme je sais de la
monoculture c'était grave pourquoi
toiture et puis aussi on pouvait se dire
bon c'est quoi le malheureux d'asand le
divin bouclé on pouvait dire ça et s'il
est nécessaire de faire front
il est où mort shuman aujourd'hui en
angleterre je crois qui vit bien il est
tranquille tous et à toutes les chansons
de presse les élus disent oui elle a
derrière lui pour lui sur le lac majeur
pistoles est majeur plus haut avec
d'autres musées way we dance avoir ça va
pour l'homme aux biens alors par contre
ça où ça s'est moins bien passé donc
faut le dire aller avec sophie marceau
parce que qu'est ce qu'ils savaient de
la zone qui a eu l'idée d'appeler le 10
mai risque neuf mois alors bravo je
résume du résultat parce que je voyais
les fuck you barcelone qui pour toi été
à bin ça se raconte comme s'ils étaient
sur moi important
oui ça sent raconte comment lors d'une
petite [ __ ] il y avait une enveloppe qui
après a fait vanessa paradis donc comme
quoi tu vois à on prend les mêmes mais
voilà bah oui oui cela dit que le mot
shoah dit ouais elle était adorable et
aller à doha
oui mais bon et leurs jours
quand même ces boules ya de la vie vous
étiez dans un studio en train d'essayer
de faire chanter sophie marceau oui il
ya les vanessa paradis qui dormait sur
un canapé à 3 heures du matin se
réveille bravery elle dit mais pourquoi
c'est pas à moi qu'on fait sans raison
comme ça mais avant à ce pont des as a
way that correspondent à une enfant qui
voulait gpal avait présenté prime qui
voulaient qui vous laisse vous voyez
quoi et qui est du loyer mais on peut
penser fascine encore une fois dire
après comme ça et tu voyais là
star tu la voyait plus comme catella bon
et ben ça chante et que tu vois cela
n'associe pas faux c'était une chose
personne qui chante les fuck you
barcelone vanessa paradis présent et de
périgueux voilà reconnaît que plus d'un
an s'est passé ouais mais le rendez vous
a été pris un set est terrible je le
sentais tu as touché le le pognon de joe
pesci l'allier l'ariège comme ça avec
romain sola banon mais il s'en vante
dans la maison etc sous et bat ça mais
tu sais je suis un petit gars du moi je
te dis un truc tu dis si si on n'arrive
pas c'est la faire passer le sentiment
le commerce suivra ouais j'ai dit ça et
c'est bien j'ai tellement sexy surtout
dit que un tout petit peu d'émotion au
fond d'un sillon c'était un filon d'or
j'écoute et surtout comme ça que je me
vois c'est à dire que bon aussi si tu
n'y a rien de plus dur que de fermer
parce qu'en fait faire vrai c'est une
façon de fabriquer ya rien de plus
bon le taxi on va pas dire que c'est
l'épistémologie la sexualité des mouches
combien millions quand bien même il
des millions de nos francs beaucoup de
millions de nos francs oui enfin bon je
me suis dit l'auteur d'accord ça fait
pas mal de temps de construire ici
continue pour aller où
alors par contre c'est un mauvais moment
que vous le dire oui tout ça tout ce
qu'on raconte la candidate d'un réel par
contre quand tu as fait la porte marine
au seuil en 81
tu fais un bouquin dans donc après tout
ce qui était fait accuser en arrivant à
paris
tu sais un bouquin et ce bouquin fumait
beaucoup de toi même comme on met tous
dans le livre et tu mets tout une valse
mais comme on essaye de voir mais on
peut pas dire que l'accueil
je suis pas exagèrer peut-être un peu
mais l'accueil à parité est normalement
et eu à résoudre tyran mais non tu as
raison bon bonnes critiques
pas jean pierre de critiques machin pour
les situer le débat critique sauf
d'ailleurs sauf ne dans le quotidien
oui j'ai retrouvé celle là toi cloche
dans cette optique dit servat se vendent
comme des petits pains serait du temps
extrait juillet ce qui est vrai mais si
c'était à refaire au fond il serait
écrit rhin écoute voilà je sais pas
reliés c'est bien que tu me dises ça
si des gens chez gallimard mme avait
accepté un manuscrit 60 3 je serais
aujourd'hui va semblablement un petit
pont d'espagne allegri